[MUSIC PLAYING]
NAVEEN CHAND: We're going
to be talking about CSP
and hybrid identity today.
So it's a topic that I'm very
excited to share with you guys.
So my name is Naveen Chand.
I'm a product manager.
I work on GCP Identity.
Today I'll be joined with my
esteemed colleague, Breno,
who is an engineer working
on GCP identity, as well.
We introduced
Anthos two days ago,
which is the latest innovation
in hybrid multi cloud that
allows you to modernize
your applications,
automate policy, provide
security at scale,
and have your
applications run anywhere,
either on premise
or in any cloud.
At the center of a lot of these
scenarios is really identity.
In order to be able to achieve
these true hybrid, cross-cloud,
cross-platform type
of capabilities,
a strong notion of
identity is required
both for policy as
well as seamless access
across these different systems.
And so in today's
talk, we'll be walking
through a deep dive in a
couple of specific use cases
around hybrid identity,
starting with GCP Hybrid
Identity and BeyondCorp.
We'll then talk a little bit
about authentication inside
of Kubernetes, getting into
things like workload identity,
on how you can actually go
start using workloads that
exist in different
systems, get access across
without having to do
things like key exchanges
or downloading specific
user keys or service keys.
And the final thing that
we'll talk about today
is really around Istio identity.
So to tee it up GCP
and Hybrid Identity,
along with BeyondCorp.
Now, the first thing
is really, when
working in a hybrid
environment, you
need to get your users
to get access to GCP.
And so after you've
created your organization,
one of the first things to do
is to go and start figuring out
how to grant your
developers, the rest
the folks that actually need
access to the environment
permissions.
And so to grant access, we use
something called Google Cloud
Identity, which is a Google
service that allows customers
to create and manage
users, as well as groups,
in order to grant them
access to cloud resources.
Now in addition to
granting access to GCP,
Google Cloud Identity is
also a standalone offering.
It has IDaaS capabilities
that allows it to do things
like robust lifecycle
management, device
policies, provisioning of
users across a multitude
of different applications.
If your identities
are actually residing
in an on prem, just
like this example shows,
you can synchronize it using
a tool called Google Cloud
Directory Synchronization,
or GCDS for short.
This tool allows you to select
the specific users using
LDAP across either
an LDAP filter
to select which set of users
you want to bring in or select
the set of OUs that
you have in order
to pull those identities in.
In order to configure single
sign on, you can use SAML,
either in this case
using an ADFS instance,
or any really federation
token broker that
allows you to take identities
from your on-prem system,
present a SAML assertion that
can be used in order to grant
them single sign on into GCP.
If your company happens to use
one of these other identity
platforms, many of
them have capabilities
built in that allow you to do
things like provision users,
and you configure the single
sign on directly with GCP
already.
Next, we're going to talk a
little bit about BeyondCorp.
Now, starting in 2011, Google
introduced a new approach
to how to do access management,
which was called BeyondCorp
Security Model.
It's a zero-trust security
model, and what that means is,
you don't rely on the
permissions or specific network
configurations or
making sure somebody
has to reside on your
corporate network
in order to gain access.
But instead, it verifies
properties of the requester,
making sure that this requester
has access and permissions
to the specific resources
that they're gaining access.
So it shifts the focus from
using network perimeter
to individual users and devices
and using those in order
to decide whether or not
somebody should gain access.
And this allows employees to
work seamlessly, regardless
of where they're located.
So we're going to spend
a couple of minutes
and look a little bit
closer into BeyondCorp
and how it can be used
in a hybrid environment.
Before we get there though,
just going a little deeper
into BeyondCorp, it has--
For BeyondCorp, there's
several different components
that are needed in order to be
able to make up the solution.
One is a notion of
strong user identity,
and while it doesn't
require you to use
phishing-resistant
technology, it definitely
works very well with that.
So you can use notions
like security keys
in order to make sure that
the requester that's coming in
is actually accessing the
location that they need.
It also leverages
context information
about their request,
so things like
where the request
is originating from,
and in addition, looks at
things like device posture
to see what type of device is
this request actually coming
from, as well.
Using those two
types of information,
it pulls it into a
centralized policy
engine that allows both
IT teams to go define
these types of policies
that says only devices that
have the following
security postures
and these specific
classes of users
can get access to this
resource, and then uses
a centralized enforcement
point in order
to be able to ensure
that this type of access
is consistently administered
regardless of where
a person is coming in from.
So Google Cloud provides a
solution for the BeyondCorp
product, and it's comprised
of several different products
inside of Google, one of
which is Cloud Identity that
allows you to take
care of the identity
as well as the context
information in terms
of what devices this request
is actually coming in from.
There's another component
around a rules engine,
and that's done through
Access Context Manager that
allows you to go in, look
at information around kind
of origination of the
request, device posture,
in order to make
that authentication
and authorization decision.
We also use VPC security
control service controls
that improve your ability
to mitigate the risk of data
exfiltration from Google
managed services things
like Cloud Storage, BigQuery.
You can actually do a boundary
around all these services
to ensure that all your data
retains within those walls.
It also uses IAM, which is
Identity and Access Management,
that allows you to specify
granular controls on resources
to decide whether or not
a specific user should
have access to that resource.
And the final piece
is really Cloud IAP.
Now Cloud IAP, or
Identity-Aware Proxy,
is a GCP service that provides
off-the-shelf authentication
and authorization
for applications
that are deployed on GCP.
It is also the starting
point for many customers
to retire their legacy
VPNs and use Google's
context-aware access story.
But while this works
great for scenarios
that exist on Google
Fabric, the reality
is many customers
have applications
that actually run either
in an on-prem environment
or in another cloud.
So IAP also now
supports the ability
to protect your workloads no
matter where they're located.
Numerous customers are now
routing traffic that actually
goes through Google's front
ends, leverages IAP, and then
forwards the encrypted traffic
back to their applications,
no matter where
that application is,
and the best part is, there
are no changes required
to the application.
It all happens right
in front of it,
adding a layer of protection.
So we're going to
walk through this
in a little bit more detail.
When a user actually
connects in,
one of the things
that happens is,
the device posture
and device information
is captured and
continuously updated in one
of the databases.
When a request comes
into the system,
GCLB provides network
layer protection.
So it can do things like
protect against DDoS attacks,
provides TLS termination,
and also manages certificates
and allows you to configure
things like IP block lists.
The identity-aware proxy users
the user identity as well as
device information
in order to be
able to make access decisions.
In this case, you'll see
the IAP on-prem connector,
which is the component
that allows you--
it's an open source tool
that allows you to connect
to a on-prem back end resource.
One of the things
that needs to be done
is for that on-prem
application, you
need to configure
the network policy
so that only requests that
originate through the IAP front
end system will be able to get
access in order to truly deploy
this model end-to-end.
Once that's configured,
the BeyondCorp model
works completely
for these scenarios.
So that was the first section
talking a little bit about how
you can use GCP in
a hybrid environment
where your users are
either configured
in an external
identity source on prem
or coming from a
external IDaaS system,
talked a little bit
about BeyondCorp.
Now we're going to
switch into Kubernetes,
and then we'll talk about
how you can configure
authentication and authorization
into Kubernetes clusters using
your existing enterprise
infrastructure.
For that, I'll switch over
to my colleague, Breno.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS:
Thank you, Naveen.
NAVEEN CHAND: Thanks.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS:
So in this section,
we'll be looking into
how to authenticate
into the Kubernetes control
plane for cluster management
activities.
So we'll focus on the
usage of the Kubernetes API
through this
standard command line
interface, or CLI for short,
which is called kubectl.
And the same principles
apply to other means
of interacting with the
control plane in Kubernetes.
For instance, if you use any
of the controller devices.
So in this scenario that we
are going to look into here,
we have Jeanine is
a cloud engineer,
and she works for a
company called Zotkix.
She's just finished creating
their first Kubernetes cluster.
As Jeanine went through the
steps to create the cluster,
those steps give
her admin privilege,
which is natural because she's
just created the cluster.
But it's based on secrets that
are stored in a kubeconfig file
typically.
That's the outcome of
creating a Kubernetes cluster
through most of the procedures.
But Zotkix's security
policies outline
a set of requirements for
access to production assets.
And these requirements
are not met
by secrets is stored
in configuration
files in administrators'
laptops and other devices.
So we need to find a
different solution that
is enterprise compatible
and compatible
with security posture of
most enterprise environments.
So indeed, in most
enterprise environments,
integrating the
SSO infrastructure
is required to manage
the production workloads.
So this involves two
steps, effectively.
One is to connect
the authentication
and the credential
Management to the SSO system,
and the other is to
configure permissions
based on the centrally
managed groups.
So we will look into each
of these steps in detail.
Well, first what is available
in Kubernetes today?
So Kubernetes supports several
mechanisms to authenticate
into a cluster, but for
integration with SSO systems,
Kubernetes supports in
particular OpenIDConnect, which
also known as OIDC, and Active
Directory Federation Services,
or ADFS for short, is a
commonly deployed enterprise
system, part of the Active
Directory set of services.
And it implements an
OpenIDConnect provider,
identity provider, or IDP.
So this provides
the means for us
to enable enterprise single
sign on into a cluster.
I'm assuming in this talk
that we're using ADFS.
We're going to go into some
configuration details here,
but many other enterprises
solutions, such as Google Cloud
Identity, the Google Cloud
Identity platform, Azure
AD, Okta, to all support OIDC.
So now we're going
to show a demo
on how to register
OIDC client for ADFS.
So here we have the panel for
Active Directory Management.
We have a handy set of notes,
and we have a PowerShell.
I hope it looks
better from there.
So first, I add an application
group, and I give it a name.
NAVEEN CHAND: Is it good
and visible from outside?
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: And I will
make it a server application
type.
I need to choose a
client identifier that
is a little more easily
recalled because the one that
gets generated is random.
So it just makes painful
to copy and paste,
but I'll copy it in here and
remember it as my client ID.
Next I need to have a
register redirect URL.
I should first
choose the port that
is widely available in my
enterprise environment.
And then I can register our URL
that the points to that port.
The reason is that we
need a place to redirect
the token after
the authentication
to the user's workstation.
And here we call also
the client secret
that gets autogenerated
when we enable secret base
authentication.
So I finished creating an
open-ended client in ADFS,
but now I need to configure
a token group's rule, which
allow me to share a group's
information from Active
Directory with the
Kubernetes cluster
so we can do role
based access control.
So I have to give it some
descriptive information
so I can remember it.
But the important
thing here is also
that I need to authorize
later to grant us essentially
permissions for ADFS to
share that information
to this specific
Kubernetes client
that I registered
in the first step.
So I created the rule.
Now I'm actually saying what
I'm going to populate it with,
what is going to be
propagated by that rule.
And we'll configure this
is to use LDAP groups.
It's called the token groups.
So I'm using token groups
qualified by long domain
name, which gives them
greater security because you
can't have collisions that way.
And I'm naming the
outputting token as groups.
That's going to be the
claim name in the token,
and I'm remembering
all of this information
because I'm going to have
to configure my client,
as well as the API server
to be able to understand
how to process the
token information.
So finally, now
that I've finished
creating the configuration
of the client
and of how to share
the group's claims,
I need to grant
authorization to the client
that I created to receive
group's information.
So that's the last
command that I'm
going to run in the Windows
PowerShell as an administrator.
And we are done with
this first step.
And if you have a different
IDP, Okta or something, Cloud
Identity Platform,
Google Cloud Identity,
you're going to have a
different set of steps
to configure the
identity provider,
but most of the subsequent
steps in this conversation
here will be generic
for any provider.
So we have now some handy notes
that we took during our client
registration with the parameters
for OpenIDConnect client
that we registered.
But the kubectl CLI, the
command line interface,
also needs those parameters
to integrate with the IDP.
But in addition to the
information about the client,
basically, the OIDC
client, kubectl
also needs some information
about the provider
itself, such as where
is the provider?
So we will show how to get
that information from ADFS.
OK so here, there are
two pieces of information
that I need about
the provider itself
for my kubectl configuration.
One is where's the provider?
So I'm going to start trying--
I'm here at the ADFS server,
and it has the host information,
has the domain information.
So that gives me the
domain part of this URL.
And next I'm going to look
into the endpoint configuration
for ADFS because ADFS
has many endpoints that
serve different properties.
I look at the
OpenIDConnect endpoints,
and what is important
is there is something
that starts to dot well-known.
The part of the path before that
is where the ADFS instance is.
So I got that section of
the path is very typical.
It's just ADFS.
And now I want to
get the certificate.
So I'm looking into
the certificate
that the ADFS server uses
because the Kubernetes
cluster is not
part of my domain,
and it doesn't know the
intermediate certificates
that I have deployed in
my services, such as ADFS.
So I'm going through
the certificate two,
and I am going to export the
intermediate certificate that
is used by the ADFS server.
So I've just used
the Export Wizard,
and I had chosen a file name.
So I'm going to use that.
And we are finished with of
the parameters from the issuer.
OK, so now we have the
OIDC client parameters,
and we have the
issuer parameters.
Now we go to the API server.
We need to configure the
API server to actually
accept sign ins from this
OIDC client that we created.
So this involves
restarting the API server
with a set of flags that
enable OIDC authentication.
So this I had from
my handy notes
that I took while I did
the previous two demos,
and this is showing how
I can configure the flags
with those parameters.
And if I restart the API
server with those parameters,
it will be able to accept
OIDC authentication.
Now we are finally ready to
prepare kubectl to authenticate
to the cluster.
And kubectl remember, it needed
the OIDC client parameters
that we registered with ADFS.
It needs some server
parameters that we
got from ADFS
configuration itself,
but it also needs some
parameters from the cluster
so it knows how to talk to it.
OK?
So that's the last
set of parameters
that we need to finish this.
So recall that right after
Jeanine created the cluster,
she had the usable configuration
that gave her admin
privileges in the cluster.
So that from that
configuration actually
has all the cluster
parameters that we need.
So we are going to go look
into that file, the kubeconfig
file that was initially created
to get those parameters so
that we can package all of this
in a single file that will make
it much easier for all the
other administrators, as well
as the other users,
developers in the cluster,
to be able to authenticate.
So let's see how we can
package all this metadata.
So we have created a plug-in
to facilitate users to sign in.
Today, to get access to it, you
needed to sign in for the GKE
On-Prem .
offering.
But if you-- in
the future, we plan
to make it more
widely available.
So once you download this
plugin, you make it executable,
and if you move it to a
path, location in your path,
it will be available
for kubectl.
So now I have collected in
this file all the parameters
from the three steps
that I went before,
and I configured them as
a single command which
is kubectl.
OIDC is the name of our plugin
that was just installed,
and client config is the
name of the parameter.
Once we run, we need a
couple of the parameters
that I explained from
the cluster itself.
So now I open that
early kubeconfig file,
and I found the server name.
OK?
And I'm back into that file.
The server, your location,
the server name, and I
need the server
certificate authority.
So I gave it a
name, and I'm going
to export from there the--
this was the certificate
that was embedded
in the original
kubectl config file,
and I'm going to
basically base64 decode it
into a certificate file.
So now I have everything ready.
So you have a properly
formatted certificate stored.
I have all the parameters.
I can run that command.
And I have a file.
And so that is completely
configured with client
information, OIDC issuer
information, and cluster
information that kubectl needs
to be able to authenticate.
So this was a lot of steps.
You definitely don't want
more than one administrator
to have to go through this.
So that's why we
created this plugin.
This plugin wraps all the
parameters in one easy file.
And now you can
distribute this file
to all the users in
your organization.
OK?
So let's see how we can
actually use this file
to enable all users in the
organization to easily sign in
with OpenIDConnect.
OK.
And so we are again using
the same plugin, but now
the login command.
I chose a username for myself.
I passed the config file that
the administrator sent to me.
And I chose a kubeconfig
name where I start
my kubeconfig information.
So I'm signing in using
the ADFS sign-in page.
That's it.
That's a user experience,
and they are ready to go.
So now you have everything
starting this kubeconfig file.
I'm going to set up as
my environment variable,
so I can now just start
performing operations
of the cluster, and
I'm authenticated
using single sign-on
and leveraging
Kubernetes authorization.
So a lot of steps for the
first administrator, extremely
easy for other administrator,
other users later once
that file is packed.
You just have to run.
That's all.
OK.
Let's look now a little more
into how Kubernetes RBAC works.
Because we've figured
out how to authenticate,
now how do we grant
privileges to the cluster?
So Zotkix, again, bringing
back to their perspective,
wants to segment privileges
within the cluster.
So one situation
could be that they
require a strict separation
between production
and development workloads.
So Kubernetes allows you to
compartmentalize permissions
in this way through namespaces.
And administrators can delegate
permissions to a namespace.
Permissions can be
attached to a role,
and there are two types of
roles in Kubernetes RBAC.
One is a role with
cluster-wide scope
that's called a cluster role.
And you want a role that
has namespace-wide scope,
and that's just called role.
Roles can be granted to users
and groups using bindings.
OK?
So a cluster role binding
binds is a cluster role
to a user or a group,
and the binding
has a scope across
a cluster-wide.
A role binding,
on the other hand,
can bind either a cluster role
or a role to a user or a group,
but the binding has
namespace scope.
In the next demo, we'll show
how a Zotkix administrator
can use bindings to grant
roles to users and groups.
So I will now show demo of how
to set up the Kubernetes RBAC.
I can see my AD.
I have two users.
One is Breno, and if you
look at the properties,
he is part of a group
called cluster admin.
OK?
But we also have another
user called unprivileged,
and as we would
expect, he is not
a member of any group
except domain users.
OK?
So I am logged in to kubectl
as myself, using the plugin as
before, and I'm going to get
cluster roles for this cluster.
There's a bunch
of them, and I see
one called cluster admin
that looks suggestive.
So let's look, find more
about that cluster role.
So I am going to
inspect the cluster
role called cluster admin, and
I see that it is a cluster role.
The name is cluster admin.
And it is granted a
lot of privileges.
OK?
It can do every operation on
every resource on every API
group in the Kubernetes API.
Great.
Who can actually use that,
exercise that cluster role?
Well, I see also a role
binding called cluster admin.
Maybe that's the
one I'm looking for.
Let's look at this cluster
admin role binding.
OK.
It is a cluster role binding.
The name is cluster
admin, and it
refers to the cluster
role, cluster admin
that I had before.
So it looks all promising.
But the subject is
a system object.
That doesn't sound like
the right cluster role.
I would expect users, groups
coming from AD in that setting.
So I'm going back to my
list of role bindings,
and I found something else
called Cluster Manager.
Is that the right one?
Let's look at what the
Cluster Manager has.
It looks very similar,
but the main difference
is that the subject is the group
called cluster admin coming
from the SSO environment.
So that's indeed
the binding that
is granting me privileges to
perform all these operations.
OK?
Now I'm going to try and do the
same as the unprivileged user,
OK?
And if I remand this operation,
I can see that instead
of looking at the cluster
roles, I'm getting an error,
that they user with a
long name qualified there,
cannot list resources cluster
roles because they're not
a part of the cluster
admin group, and therefore,
they are not bound to
the Cluster Manager role
in the cluster.
We talked quite a bit
about user authentication.
I will talk about
workload identity now.
So workload identity
in Kubernetes,
there is a pre built-in
system for workload identities
in Kubernetes when we
use the Kubernetes API.
This form of Kubernetes identity
is called a service account,
and it's created in a namespace.
So Kubernetes service accounts
may be granted permissions
either via cluster role bindings
or role bindings, just as users
and groups.
So, in this example
I'm showing here
how Jenkins CI/CD workload can
be granted permission to modify
all pods in a cluster.
It also shows how the
same permission can be--
so, if you look here--
can I see the--
I don't see my--
oh.
Oh well, sorry.
I don't see the pointer, so I'm
just going to point directly.
You have a cluster
row called pod leader
which is given permissions to
modify pods in the cluster.
We have a cluster of binding
that binds this privilege
to a service account
called CI/CD,
which is your continuous
deployment tool.
And so, naturally, your
continuous deployment
needs to update
jobs in the cluster.
And so, the granting seal refers
to the cluster HomePod updater.
So, this allows
a workload that's
running the cluster with
this service identity which
runs in the production namespace
and with name CI/CD to modify
all pods in the cluster.
There is a separate
row binding here
that gives to the dev team
the ability to exercise also
the pod updater role, but only
in the namespace development.
And so, if you have
a production job,
they will not be
able to modify it.
We now have support for
workload identity in GKE
to directly exercise
privileges in GCP IAM.
So, that makes it much easier
to secure access to your GCP
resources, because you no longer
need to download and manage
GCP service accounts in GKE.
Instead, with workload
identity, the provision
of credentials for GKE
services can be fully managed.
So, if you look at
the parallel here--
in Kubernetes RBAC.
If you wanted to create,
to grant privileges,
you create the cluster role
and you create cluster role
bindings where you grant
those rows privileges
to specific users or
groups or service accounts.
In GCP IAM, RBAC, you
have a service account--
GCP service account--
and what you do
is you grant this
service account
access to some properties
in your project.
So, here, I'm granting
this GCP service account
an editor role in the project.
Then, you can exercise that
role from a Kubernetes workload
by adding a policy
binding that mentions
a workload identity in GKE.
So, that's what this
expression is describing here.
If you recall from the
example that we gave,
the namespace production
and the service
account CI/CD represented my
continuous deployment tool.
So, with this
configuration, you don't
need to create this downloader
key into your GKE deployed to.
It can directly access GCP.
OK, and this-- courtesy to
our friends in the GKE team--
I have a demonstration
of how this works.
First we are creating
a works cluster.
There is a flag
called identity space.
That tells us that this should
enable the workload identity
feature in the cluster.
So, we're looking at
the configuration here.
I have an app called GCS server.
And, it has an annotation
which refers to a GCP service
account.
So, that tells our
metadata service w
to allow the workload identity
to get tokens to talk to GCP.
And this all happens
transparently with no changes
to the application or the
provision of credentials
is using the
infrastructure of GKE.
So, just for reference, we
have the namespace and service
account and workload identity
service account there.
We are creating that GCP
account we referred to
in the annotation.
And we are seeing
that the application
that we first constructed
is now running as deployed.
We want to grant the
binding that I've
talked about where we give
the Kubernetes service
account the ability to
impersonate the GCP service
account to exercise that role.
Whoops, something
is not working.
What could possibly go wrong?
We forgot to grant, actually,
privileges to our GCP service
account that we just created.
So, it is successful
impersonating the GCP service
account, but this service
account has no privileges.
So, we can fix that.
In a minute, you'll
see how to fix that.
The error is access denied.
So, you see it mentioned
the GCP service account.
So the error was--
so now we add the permission--
see that's Echo-- and we gave
the privileges to our GCP
service account permission,
and now the job is
able to perform its operations,
correctly fetch the results,
and display them.
And this is showing that this
is a multi-cluster feature.
You can enable the
same identity--
the same role be used
by multiple clusters.
And so, we are deploying
this server in a different--
you can see east can
access and so can west.
All right, they both can
access their GCS resource.
However, if you
delete that echo--
the echo on the
service account--
you can see that the
application no longer
can access the same resource.
And you'll go back
to that scenario
where you don't have privilege.
OK, so that finishes our
demonstration of workload
identity and Kubernetes.
And now I'm going to
give you an overview
of identity authentication
in a hybrid environment.
So, EU Istio an open
source mesh that
lays transparently on the
existing and distributed
services.
And it's also
platform, including
APIs that integrate with any
logging, telemetry, or policy
system.
So, why should we consider using
Istio in my hybrid environment?
So, Istio makes
it easy to create
a network of deployed
services with load balancing,
service to service
authentication, monitoring,
and more with few or no code
changes in service code.
And it also can be
used to deliver secure,
service to service
communication in a cluster
with a strong identity-based
authentication
and authorization
based on mutual TLS.
And Google is a major
contributor of today's Istio
development and architecture.
So, it means that
by using Istio you
take advantage of some of the
best practices and strategies
from micro-service
mesh management.
So, to begin, you add
Istio support to services
by deploying a sidecar proxy
throughout your environment.
And this sidecar
proxy intercepts
all network communication
between the microservices.
One, then, can configure
and manage Istio
through its control
plane functionality.
So, it allows
Zotkix in this case
to distribute policy
throughout the mesh
as well as telemetry
configuration, audit policy,
network accessibility
rules, and so on.
And configuration is consumed
by all these envoy proxies--
both an ingress proxy if present
as well as the sidecar proxies.
And it's the policies enforced
by the infrastructure.
So, in particular, why should
you use Istio security?
Because it delivers
authentication, authorization,
and all that as part
of the platform.
So, you don't need to burden
your application developers
with getting that right.
And, in addition, you get
consistent application
of those policies.
So, much easier to
complete compliance
activities within
your environment.
OK, so, let's give
an example scenario
where Zotkix is trying
to use this tool
to provide access management to
their on-premises applications.
In this example, it's deployed
in the GKE on-prem cluster--
in particular
Kubernetes cluster--
but Istio can also
be used to protect
our workloads and more
traditional on-premise data
centers that are not
based on Kubernetes.
So here, when the corp user is
authenticated using credentials
on the corp environment
and they make a request--
let's say to the
Zotkix HR application--
the ingress proxy will
terminate the TLS connection
and enforce that their request
includes user credentials.
Later, as the request
travels down the stack,
you can have policy being
applied at every hub.
So, for instance,
if you are accessing
a method that requires
administrative privileges,
the sidecar envoy
can require that you
have those privileges
because you belong
to a particular privileged
group that has the ability
to perform that operation.
And, in between
hops, you still can
leverage both the
initial requesting user
identity as well as
the pure identity
to perform authorization.
Here, we see a scenario where
the employee is accessing
from an overseas location.
So, in this scenario,
Zotkix decided
to use the Identity
Aware Proxy--
IAP-- to take advantage
of Google's fast network--
globe-spanning network.
So, many of our
customers actually
use IP to route both traffic
to their cloud applications
as well as on-premises
applications,
because of the advantage of the
Google network connectivity.
And, by using IAP
in addition, you
get access to the context
aware authorization rules
that IAP provides.
For instance, you can configure
that some app operations
require second factor
authentication,
or that the device
is in a good state.
Now, let's look at how's Zotkix
can use the same architecture
to protect their cloud apps.
They have extended the
identity system to GCP
by using cloud identity.
By leveraging the
Identity Aware Proxy,
they have authentication,
authorization
at ingress, which
simplifies the management
for the applications.
And, in this scenario,
we showed that this
can be used to
protect the legacy
application, such as a
database VM running in GCP.
Employees also can have access
to the GKE apps controlled
this way.
Again, similar, consistent view
between the on-premise setting
and the cloud setting by
leveraging Istio and IAP.
In addition to protecting
employee-based authentication,
you can use this
infrastructure to protect
your consumer-oriented
applications--
the same architecture.
And one of the advantages
here is that authentication,
authorization, and audit--
they permeate the entire
service stack, which
reduces trust between systems.
You don't need to trust the
assertion of the user identity
from the front end
in the back end.
You can remove this
amount of service
to service trust, which
facilitates compliance
against requirements--
audit requirements--
and it also just
reduces insider risk.
Another feature of
this architecture
is that it has a strong
sense of pure identity.
By using neutral
TLS, you can have
strong assurances about the
peer that is connecting.
So here, in the
cases at back end
have a very strong confidence
that the request indeed
comes from its front end.
So, finally, we go back
to what we talked about
earlier with workload identity.
You can enable workload
identity in GKE
and now have fully managed
credentials for your workloads
where you can directly grant
access to IAM, to your workload
identity.
And you also make it much
easier and secure to consume
any GCP services, such as
cloud store or Stackdriver
from metrics.
In this scenario,
stack driver is
providing the matrix telemetry
infrastructure for Istio.
So, tying it
together, we can see
that in a hybrid
environment, Zotkix
can leverage both
open-source historic texture
and Google managed services,
such as IP and Stackdriver,
in a well-integrated
environment that
delivers consistent,
transparent, and auditable
policy enforcement.
And, in addition to the
integration of workload
identity with IAM, Zotkix can
seamlessly consume GCP services
from their GKE apps
with improved security
and eliminating the need
to manage credentials.
So, let's recap.
Summing up, we have seen
that CSP and GCP provide
robust capabilities to help you
easily connect to your existing
identify solutions.
These capabilities enable
you to uniformly manage
hybrid applications
with GKE and Istio,
and they allow you
to easily secure
your hybrid applications--
your hybrid environment.
And you can make your
applications available
anywhere securely by leveraging
BeyondCorp technology.
[MUSIC PLAYING]